the size of the reflection you see of
yourself on a mirror never changes size
no matter what you do watch right now
you fit perfectly inside that rectangle
but if you come closer you continue to
always just fill that rectangle and if
you move really far away like if you
come all the way back here guess what
you still just fit in that area oh and
guess what the size of the image that
you see of yourself on the surface of a
mirror is always just no matter where
you stand half of your actual size now
this happens because the image that you
see of yourself in a mirror appears to
be just as far behind the mirror as you
are in front of the mirror so your
reflection appears to be twice as far
away as the mirror no matter where you
stand making it always appear to be half
the size you would be if you were
actually at the
mirror